ده تحيه رياضيه تحيه كرويه خالصه من هنا
من فضاء المشجعين ظلفان في ضاحيه الشماليه
منطقه جمارك بيتونس العاصمه تقريب اقل من
اربع ساعات الانذار اليوم تتوجه الى ملعب
المدينه التعليميه والموقع الاخيره لنسور
ضد الديوك الفرنسيه تقريبا هنا قبل اربع
ساعات بدات الاجواء في هذا الفضاء تحذيرا
لهذه الموقع مشجع والفريق التونسي بداوا
في التوافق الى هذا المكان بالاعلام
التونسيه يترشحون العالم التونسيه
ويرفعونها في ايديهم وكل الامل
ان تحقق النخبه التونسيه الفريق الوطني
التونسي ما يعتبر اليوم كرويا معجزه
رياضيه بالفوز على الفريق الفرنسي وانتظار
نتيجه الدنمارك واستراليا في الحقيقه
الاجواء هنا تكاد تكون ايضا في كل بيت
التونسيون اليوم يتحدثون كره وايضا في
المقاهي التي بدات في الاستعداد منذ
الليله الماضيه لتبيعه الحدث الذي يعلق
عليه التونسيون امالا كبيره خاصه مع
البدايه المشجع ضد الفريق الدنماركي ولكن
النكسه التي حدثت معه استراليا جعلت
الحظوظ تتقلص احمد التونسي
ظهر بوجهين الاول كان جيدا مع الدنمارك
والثاني سيء مع استراليا ولذلك ما الذي
يعول عليه بحسب ما يراه المراقبون لي ظهور
المنتخب التونسي بالوجه الاول
ما هو كذلك احمد لا حل امام الناخب الوطني
اليوم جلال القادر سيول الانتصار ولا شيء
غير الانتصار هناك بعض التسريبات عن
التشكيله المحتمله التي سيدخل عليها جلال
القادري تعديلات في الخطوط الثالثه حتى
تكون ذات صبغه هجومي اكثر من المنتظر ان
يعول على الحارس دحمان منذ بدايه اللقاء
ثلاثي الدفاع ابطال
في الاجنحه كشريده واعليه معلول لاول مره
ربما مع الخماسي في وسط المعتاد مع
امكانيه محمد علي بن رمضان وايضا السخيري
مع الاعتماد على العدوني وقد يعتمد في
الهجوم على وهب الخصر الكرام راس حربه
مهاجم على كل سنستطلع الامر مع الصحفي
الرياضي زياد السلم زياد اهلا بك الى شاشه
العربيه اليوم ماسينا روايه ممكن
تكتيكي عفوا الذي قد يدخل به القادري
لمقعه النسور ضد الديوك ولا حل امامها
شكرا لك زميل وليد مثل تحدث منذ قليل
استمع اليك ولكل المشاهدين طبعا هو لقاء
المعزه هو اللي قال امل الاخير وهو ايضا
لقاء لا مستحيل طبعا اكيد مثل ما شاهدت
التشكيل طبعا هناك عناصر جديده تدخل كان
من اجل ان يكون في بدايه يعني المواجهات
خاصه في المواجهه الفيصل يعني هو كان
يعتبروه لقاء استراليا كان لقاء المفتاح
لان هناك بعد لقاء الدنمارك الذي اعاد
الامل واعاد الفرحه لكل التونسي اليوم هنا
الجمهور ياتي منذ ساعات السباحه الاولى
طبعا لقاء استراليا طبعا لقاء للنسيان
اليوم لقاء هو لقاء الفرصه الاخيره ولقاء
يعني اعاده الامل ولا ننسى ان سنلعب بان
النسور امام الديوك الفرنسيه امام بطل
العالم بطل العالم اليوم يدافع على لقبه
في مونديال الدوحه طبعا صعب جدا صحيح
الامل يعود لتونسيين صحيح شفنا بعد مراره
الخاصه بعد الامل زياد قراءه في التشكيله
المحتمله تقريبا كل الاسرار عند القاضي
ولكن هل من المنتظر ان يكون الرسم
التكتيكي هجومي اكثر ام تغطي الدفاع مع
الحضاره لا يمكن اليوم الحديث عن الدفاع
اليوم هو هم المردود اليوم اللي يهم
تونسيين اليوم لكل التونسيين سواء في تونس
او في خرجها همم لا شيء الا سواء الانتساب
مهما ستكون الرسم التكتيك كنت نشوف
التشكيله المتوقعه يعني مع الامام علي
معلول ايضا وهبي الخزري ايضا محمد علي بن
رمضان ايضا العديد الذي حاضر الصخيري
اليوم لا يهم مردود اليوم ليس الدفاع وانا
ما له هجوم وان اليوم هو تحقيق الانتساب
وهذا وتنتظر يعني اكيد لقاء ايضا الدنمارك
واستراليا في نفس التوقيت طبعا هذا هو انه
امن اليوم تونس هو الذي شيء الا غير
الانتصار اليوم شكرا لك زياده صافي
ولا شيء غير الانتصار هذا ما ينتظره
التونسيون لليوم احمد فقط ان كان لدينا
مزيد من الوقت حتى نستطلع اراء بعض
الجماهير الحاضره هنا في هذا همم
على هذا المكان اهلا وسهلا انتم معنا الان
في المباشر على العربيه نعم في دقيقه
واحده سنحاول نستطلع الامر احمد انتظارتكم
وتوقعاتكم اللي ماتش اليوم وقعت النسور مع
الديوك والله احنا ننتظر وانه نسور قرطاج
يعطيه وكل الجهد ويعطيه ويلعبوا بروح
رياضيه اقوى ان شاء الله نكونوا في حسن
الظن بالشعب التونسي واحنا كل الحب
والتشجيع المنتخب وان شاء الله يا رب
كل الحب وكل التشجيع متفائله اليوم
امكانيه تحقيق ربما صح ولا النسور
دقيقه ان شاء الله